hey this is kind of funny I think you'll
like this I've talked on the show before
about how I'm I guess what you would
call vertically challenged I'm only 5/8
and people sometimes when they meet me
especially when people would meet me and
Lois who was taller than me or
especially if people stop me and Pat who
Pat's even taller than Louis's people
are often sort of confused by actually
how short I am and as a result roofie
which is a Canadian shoe company
sponsored this video and sent me a free
pair of their shoes which make you seven
centimeters or 2.75 inches taller
depending on how you measure it and at
first it all just seemed kind of funny
and like yeah i get it i'm 5-8 whatever
but i got the shoes and it's actually
there it's like a nice pair of leather
shoes they're very light they're soft
really really flexible it looks like a
normal dress shoe from the outside but
it has a nearly three inch lift on the
inside so you can't really tell when you
have it on that it may be an artificial
height enhancement I check out their
website and they've got not just the
style that I got but also other colors
other Styles etc they've got a size
guide also so you can figure out based
on the size of your foot what size this
is what size you are in this shoe and
you can check it all out at FECA that's
o o FY dot CA and the proof is in the
pudding I mean very clearly I'm nearly
511 when I wear these shoes instead of
5/8 and the the real test will be when I
wear these out will anyone look at me
and say something looks sort of
different about you I guess I'll have to
try it and see you can check it out at
FECA
oo FY dot CA check it out send me your
thoughts if you decide to try it